lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hablar un poco del riñón esta es una
imagen grande de un riñón y hablar de
cómo opera en el menor nivel funcional
que es la nefrona hablaremos de él
nyon
y de la cne
na
y creo que ya sabes que tenemos dos
riñones es el órgano más conocido por
permitirnos
cree
sustancias de desecho pero parte de ese
proceso y déjame escribir excretar sus
si has
yo
nos ayuda a man
leer
nuestra agua en un nivel adecuado
también la cantidad de sales y de
electrolitos que tenemos y nuestra
presión sanguínea pero sólo diré
mantener
guau
y también produce
x
no
entre otras cosas pero no voy a entrar
en muchos detalles acerca de eso ahora
solo quiero enfocarme en estas primeras
dos para intentar entender la función
general del riñón la mayoría de nosotros
tenemos dos de estos están cerca de
nuestra espalda a ambos lados de nuestra
espina dorsal atrás de nuestro hígado y
esta es una ampliación de un riñón
el riñón no es tan grande si lo estás
viendo en pantalla completa no será tan
grande como esta imagen pero lo
rebajamos para poder ver lo que está
pasando adentro del riñón y para
entender las diferentes partes aquí esto
será significativo cuando empecemos a
hablar de las unidades funcionales de la
nefrona dentro del riñón esta área de
aquí de aquí a acá esta es llamada
kurt
cada vez que hablamos de algo
relacionado al riñón si ves un término
con la palabra renal se refiere al riñón
esto de aquí es una corteza renal es la
parte exterior de ahí y luego esta área
de aquí esta de aquí ésta es la médula
renal la palabra médula viene de centro
o parte interior puedes ver esto como el
centro del riñón me tú
y nadie
y además de entender estas palabras
vamos a ver que de hecho juegan un papel
muy importante en esta filtración en
esta expresión de desperdicios y el no
excretar demasiada agua cuando
intentamos filtrar nuestra sangre
mencioné antes y seguramente ya lo has
oído en otras clases o de otros maestros
que la unidad funcional de riñón es la
nefrona
yo
en la razón por la cual es conocida como
unidad funcional y déjame ponerla entre
comillas es porque es el nivel en el
cual estas dos funciones están
sucediendo las dos principales la
expresión de desperdicios y el
mantenimiento del nivel de agua en la
sangre sólo para tener una idea de cómo
la nefrona entra en esta imagen del
riñón y tengo que decir que obtuve esta
imagen de wikipedia el dibujante intento
hacer un par de nefronas por aquí la
nefrona se vería algo así y se extiende
en esta dirección hasta la médula luego
regresa a la corteza y luego vuelca en
ductos colectivos y esencialmente el
fluido va a acabar en los
justo aquí y acabar en nuestra vejiga
urinaria que luego podemos vaciar cuando
encontremos un tiempo adecuado y bueno
supongo que podrás imaginar la longitud
de una nefrona
aquí empieza y vuelve a bajar hasta acá
múltiples nefrona seguirán haciendo eso
pero son muy delgadas estos tubos o más
bien túbulos son muy delgados y la
cantidad de neuronas en un riñón
promedio está en el orden de un millón
mi sol
más
realmente no se puede decir que tus
neuronas son microscópicas por lo menos
su longitud cuando bajan hasta la médula
puedes decir puedo ver esa distancia
puedes aún juntar muchas de ellas
adentro de un riñón ahora entendemos
como una nefrona filtra la sangre y cómo
se asegura que no demasiada agua o no
muchos nutrientes en nuestra sangre
acaben en la orina déjame dibujar aquí
una nefrona empezaré de esta manera
empezaremos con el flujo sanguíneo
el flujo vendrá en arterias este es un
capilar arterial podrías decir vendrá de
esta manera esta es de hecho llamada
yo la
en que no tienes que saber los nombres
pero podrías verlos en alguna ocasión la
sangre ingresa y luego llega a este
lugar con muchas curvas este lugar
grande con muchas curvas y luego giran
alrededor de esta manera esto es llamado
lo merula este es el plomero lo lo
me
no
y luego se va por la anterior la
diferente esta es la
hola
diferente solo significa alejarse del
centro diferente hacia el centro
diferente es alejarse del centro y
hablaré más de esto en el futuro pero es
interesante que aún estamos lidiando con
arterias en este punto aún es sangre
oxigenada normalmente cuando dejamos un
sistema capilar como el comerlo aquí
normalmente estamos lidiando con el
sistema venoso pero aquí aún estamos en
un sistema arterial y es probable porque
los sistemas arteriales tienen presión
sanguínea mayor y lo que tenemos que
hacer es exprimir fluido y sustancias
que están disueltas en el fluido afuera
de la sangre y en el plomero lo aquí el
plomero lo es muy poroso y está rodeado
por otras células déjame solo dibujar
esta es una sección transversal
está rodeado de esta manera por esta
estructura y estas de aquí son células
puedes imaginar que todas estas son
células y por supuesto los capilares
tienen células que los recubre hay
células aquí dibujé estas líneas estas
líneas están de hecho hechas de pequeñas
células lo que sucede es que la sangre
ingresa con una presión muy alta esto es
muy poroso estas células aquí afuera son
llamadas podocitos son un poco más
selectivas en lo que se filtra y
esencialmente tienes aproximadamente un
quinto del fluido que ingresa cerca de
una quinta parte del fluido que entra
acaba yendo a este espacio llamado
espacio de bowman
de hecho toda esta llamada cápsula de
bowman
puedes imaginarla como una esfera con
una apertura aquí donde los capilares
pueden enrollarse en el interior y el
espacio aquí este es el espacio de
bowman el espacio dentro de la cápsula
de bomba
bowman y toda la cápsula tiene células
todas estas estructuras están hechas
obviamente o quizá no es tan obvio están
hechas de células y entonces acabamos
con
fin
y lo medular en ella el filtrado es sólo
lo que se exprime de la sangre no
podemos decirle orina aún porque hay
muchos pasos que tienen que ocurrir para
poder llamar la orina así que solo es
filtrado ahora y esencialmente lo que se
exprime hacia afuera mencioné es
aproximadamente un quinto del fluido y
sustancias que son fáciles de disolver
en el fluido iones pequeños como el
sodio
quizá moléculas pequeñas como la club co
sa y tal vez algunos
a mí no
2 hay muchas sustancias aquí pero esto
es solo para darte una idea
y las que no son filtradas son cosas
como los glóbulos rojos o moléculas y
proteínas más grandes no se filtrara
nada de esto solo son las micro
moléculas las que serán filtradas serán
parte de este filtrado que se muestra
aquí arriba en el espacio de bowman
ahora el resto de lo que hace la nefrona
la cápsula de forman es como el inicio
de la neurona solo para conocer la idea
o lo general de nuestro riñón digamos
que estamos cerca de una arteria la esta
es la cápsula de bowman se ve algo así
y toda la nefrona será enrollada de esta
manera bajará hasta la médula y luego
regresará y luego llegará a un ducto
colectivo y hablaré más acerca de eso lo
que he dibujado aquí
esta es una ampliación
esta parte
ahora lo que quiero hacer es alejarme un
poco porque se me acaba el espacio
déjame alejarme un poco tenemos una
pero la entrando todos se agrupa en el
plomero y la mayor parte de la sangre se
va pero un quinto de ella es filtrada en
la cápsula de bowman esta de aquí es la
cápsula de bowman solo me aleje un poco
tenemos nuestro filtrado aquí lo haré en
amarillo
tenemos nuestro filtrado aquí el
filtrado que acaba de salir en este
punto algunas veces el llamado filtrado
glomerular porque es filtrado por el
club merlo pero también está filtrado
por podocitos en el interior de la
cápsula de bowman pero ahora está listo
para ir al túbulo proximal déjame
dibujarlo
esta manera
y no es exactamente como se ve pero te
da la idea esto de aquí
es el
lo
mal y suena como una palabra bastante
rebuscado pero proximal solo significa
cerca y túbulo como te podrás imaginar
simplemente quiere decir pequeño tubo es
este pequeño tubo que está cerca del
inicio por eso se le conoce como túbulo
proximal y tiene dos partes todo el
conjunto es normalmente llamado túbulo
contorneado proximal túbulo
con thor
mía
y eso es porque está todo contorneado la
manera en la que lo dibujé fue con
muchas curvas y solo lo dibujé con
curvas en dos dimensiones pero tiene
curvas en las tres dimensiones la
realidad es que hay una parte con curvas
y luego hay una parte recta cerca del
final del túbulo proximal llamamos a
todo esto el túbulo proximal esta es la
parte contorneado está en la parte recta
pero no tenemos que ser tan meticulosos
la función principal de esta parte de la
neurona y solo para recordar en dónde
estamos
estamos ahora en este punto de la
nefrona justo allí el objetivo principal
es empezar a reabsorber algunas de las
sustancias que están en el filtrado que
no queremos perder no queremos perder
glucosa al ser una sustancia que nos
costó trabajo ganar al comer porque nos
ayuda a tener energía no queremos perder
demás
a 2 sodio hemos visto en múltiples
vídeos que es unión útil y no queremos
perder aminoácidos esos son útiles para
formar proteínas y otras cosas estas son
sustancias que no queremos perder así
que empezamos a absorber las de regreso
haré todo un vídeo de exactamente lo que
pasa pero se hace activamente estamos
usando atp y solo como un breve resumen
estás usando atp para de hecho bombear
hacia afuera el sodio y luego eso ayuda
a que entren las otras sustancias eso es
sólo una pequeña parte de lo que está
pasando estamos re absorbiendo sólo
imagina lo que está sucediendo tiene
células que recubren el túbulo proximal
de hecho tienen pequeñas partes que
sobresalen haré todo un vídeo de estas
porque de hecho son muy interesantes
tenemos células aquí
y del otro lado de las células tienes un
sistema arterial o debería de decir
mejor un sistema capilar digamos que
tienes un sistema capilar aquí
que está muy cerca de las células que
recubren el túbulo proximal y entonces
estas sustancias son bombeadas
activamente especialmente el sodio pero
todas ellas usando energía son bombeadas
de regreso a la sangre de manera
selectiva y quizá un poco de agua así
que tendremos estamos bombeando de
regreso algo de sodio
club
y empezaremos a bombear un poco del agua
de regreso porque no queremos perder a
toda esa agua si toda el agua que está
originalmente en el filtrado la
dejáramos en nuestra orina excretar y
amos litros y litros de agua diariamente
y es algo que no queremos hacer ese es
el objetivo principal
empezamos el proceso de absorción y
luego vamos a entrar en la casa de él y
de hecho esta es la que considero como
la parte más interesante estamos
entrando en el asa de él y va hasta
abajo pero luego vuelve a arriba la
mayor parte de la longitud de la nefrona
es la asa de l
y vuelvo a este diagrama si menciono a
la casa de él me refiero a todo esto
justo ahí y puedes ver algo interesante
aquí cruza el borde entre la corteza
esta parte café claro y la médula renal
esta parte rojiza o anaranjada justo ahí
y hace eso por una razón muy buena la
dibujaré aquí digamos que esta es la
línea divisora justo aquí esta de aquí
es la cura
t
esta de aquí
fue la
me too
el objetivo principal bueno más bien hay
dos objetivos de la sade l
d
un objetivo es
me to la
rey
mal
y logra esto bombeando activamente sales
hacia afuera y hace eso en la parte
ascendente del asa de él
bombea sales hacia fuera activamente
sodio
estacio
lo juro
bombea al exterior activamente estas
sales para hacer a la médula salada en
su totalidad o si pensamos en eso en
términos de algo parecido a la ósmosis
la hace hipertónica tienes más absoluto
aquí que el que tienes en el filtrado
que va a través del túbulo así que lo
que hace es y utiliza atp para hacer
esto esto requiere atp para bombear
activamente en contra de un gradiente de
concentración está
la tal
la
y es salada por una razón no es solo
para recuperar estas sales del filtrado
aunque esa es parte de la razón pero al
hacer la salada esta parte la parte
ascendente es solo permeable a estas
sales y estos iones no es permeable al
agua
permeable
agua por el contrario la parte
descendente de la sade l sólo es
permeable al agua o no
guau
qué sucederá si todo esto es salado
porque la parte ascendente está
bombeando activamente sales qué pasará
con el agua mientras fluye a través de
la parte descendente bueno esto de aquí
afuera es hipertónico el agua
naturalmente querrá salir y hacer que la
concentración se balancee hice todo un
vídeo de eso no ocurre por arte de magia
y entonces el agua ya que esto es
hipertónico es más salado y ya que esto
solo es permeable al agua el agua va a
salir de la membrana en la parte
descendente del asa de l ahora
y esa es la mayor parte de la
reabsorción de agua y pensé por qué no
usamos atp de alguna manera para bombear
agua activamente y la respuesta ahí es
que no hay una manera sencilla de hacer
eso
los sistemas biológicos son buenos
usando atp para bombear guiones pero no
pueden bombear activamente agua manejar
agua es algo difícil para las proteínas
la solución es hacer esto salado
bombeando iones hacia afuera y después
el agua si haces esto únicamente por uso
al agua el agua fluirá hacia fuera
naturalmente así que este es un
mecanismo principal para recuperar mucha
del agua que se filtró aquí arriba y la
razón por la cual esto es tan largo es
para dar tiempo a esta agua de salir y
esa es la razón por la cual fluye
fácilmente y con distancia suficiente
hacia esta porción salada de abajo y
después vamos a dejar el asa de él y
casi acabamos con la nefrona luego
estamos en otro túbulo contorneado y no
adivinarás el nombre de este túbulo
contorneado si éste fuera el proximal
este sería el lista
y de hecho solo para hacer bien mi
dibujo de hecho pasa muy cerca de la
cápsula de bowman así que déjame hacerlo
en un color distinto
el túbulo contorneado distal de hecho
pasa muy cerca de la cápsula de bowman
nuevamente solo estoy haciendo las
curvas en dos dimensiones pero de hecho
tiene curvas en las tres
y no es así de largo pero tenía que
llevarlo hasta acá y quería que llegara
a este punto de ahí el llamado distal
distales alejado está contorneado y es
un túbulo este de aquí es el
no
thor
y aquí tenemos más absorción de calcio
más reabsorción de sodio solo estamos re
absorbiendo más sustancias que no
queríamos perder desde un principio hay
muchas sustancias que podemos mencionar
que se reabsorben pero ésta es sólo la
idea general y también re absorbemos una
pequeña cantidad adicional de agua pero
luego al final justo aquí nuestro
filtrado ha sido procesado mucha agua ha
sido retirada está mucho más concentrado
y hemos re absorbido muchas de las sales
y electrolitos que necesitamos que
absorbemos la glucosa y muchos de los
aminoácidos todo lo que necesitamos lo
hemos re absorbido así que estos son
básicamente productos de desecho y agua
que ya no necesitamos y esto se desecha
en los túbulos colectores esto se
desecha en túbulos colectores y puedes
ver esto como el ducto de basura del
riñón donde múltiples nefronas
desecharán
ese podría ser el túbulo cristal de otra
nefrona este es el túbulo colector
yo
thor
que es solo un tubo que está conectando
todos los subproductos de las nefronas y
lo interesante es que estos túbulos
colectores van hacia la médula otra vez
van a la parte salada nuevamente
si hablamos de los túbulos colectores
quizá los túbulos colectores vuelven a
la medular colectando todos los
filtrados de las diferentes neuronas y
debido a que va de regreso a ese lugar
super salado en la médula de hecho
tenemos cuatro hormonas llamadas
hormonas antidiurética que determinan la
porosidad de este túbulo colector y si
lo hacen muy poroso permiten que más
agua fluya hacia la médula porque es muy
salada el agua se irá si esto está
poroso y si eso pasa el filtrado que
quizás ahora si podemos empezar a llamar
orina se concentrará aún más de manera
que perderemos todavía menos agua y
sigue recolectando y recolectando hasta
que acabamos aquí sale del riñón y va a
través de los uréteres a la vejiga
urinaria
espero encuentres esto útil y creo que
lo más interesante aquí es como re
absorbemos activamente el agua en la asa
de l